natural selection a process which at
once favored the noblest traits of man
now began to favor different traits
we could just call this like the libs of
tick tock day because I'm mostly going
to be harvesting directly from her
Twitter feed I can only just hope and
continue to hope that she doesn't get
banned from Twitter because that would
be like 80 of my show prep out the
window anyway let's uh let's go through
these we'll start with clip six my
friend I know that you mean well but I
need to let you know that this is not
true first things first paganism is not
one religion and pagans have many varied
beliefs yeah right now I'm something of
a pagan myself and I can personally
assure you that Faye pronouns are not
offensive to me and if they're offensive
to you it doesn't really matter to me
because they remain my pronouns and now
for the part of the program where I
issue Corrections because this is very
interesting I I don't know why you chose
they say self pronouns or to use the
word paganists when pagans would work
just fine people against goodness and
normalcy Pagan I get the distinct
feeling that you've never googled this
to confirm it which is something that I
highly highly advise you do before you
repeat stuff in the future have a great
day uh I would advise the opposite I
would advise that you do not Google Fey
Fey self pronouns because it will send
you down a rabbit hole you don't want to
go down so apparently What's Happening
Here is we're dropping into the middle
of a debate among Tick-Tock pagans and
the debate is about whether Fey pronouns
are offensive to their Tick-Tock Pagan
culture and by the way I did actually I
took his recommendation and I did look
it up Faye pronouns are self-identified
fairies that means that most of us have
been misgendering the Tooth Fairy all
this time hello hi I think we had kind
of this sexist assumption that tooth
Fair is a female I've always referred to
her as a female but we should have been
saying Faye I guess by the way how does
that work so your pronoun
is now just your noun like it so you're
a fairy and that and then fairy is your
pronoun if you're an elephant then your
pronouns are I don't know Ella and Fant
how does that make any sense so what
else is there to say about this first
elephant in the room speaking of
elephants it's kind of ironic if this
guy does identify as a tooth fairy given
the state of his
teeth
Matt Walsh is being mean I mean come on
I don't mean to be rude I just I'm like
pointing out the irony second this is
what happens when people are abandoned
to their delusions because this person
is just lost
in a tornado of of that sees
it's like it's like The Wizard of Oz
moment and he's and he's Dorothy in the
whole house has been uprooted and the
wicked witch is flying around there like
that's that's his whole that's his mind
right now is that
his whole life is overtaken by
and it's clearly not making him happy
that's one of the real
um important insights I think that you
can find if you if you uh do go to tick
tock and and you know you find the
leftist on Tick Tock and you start
watching some other stuff like yeah it's
all nonsense and it's crazy but maybe
even more importantly you see that this
is these are not happy people
part of the attraction I think for this
stuff uh for these people is that they
think it's going to make them happy yes
and it doesn't I think it also it gives
them something
that they can be an expert in okay it's
a subject they can learn and be
authorities in
so this guy's an authority in in Neo
pronouns and he's uh and he's delivering
a lecture in Neo pronouns now the
subject that he's an authority in is
again it's total nonsense it
doesn't mean anything it's all a lot of
simple tricks and nonsense but it's this
invented game they've made up and he's
an authority in those rules it's hard to
even parse this and say what's the worst
part about all this but that's that's
one of the worst things about it is that
it causes people to just focus their
lives on this stuff that it just it's
total complete nonsense okay you're
bored you want to find something to do
with your life find any other subject
become an expert in any any real thing
that's happening in the world and focus
on that instead you know hiring used to
be really hard you'd post your job on
multiple sites you'd hope the right
people see it and then you would wait
for them to apply well now there's a
place you can go that makes hiring
faster and easier it's called zip
recruiter head to ziprecruiter.com Walsh
and try it for free right now zipper
Critters matching technology excels at
finding the most qualified candidates
for a wide range of roles see a
candidate you like well you can easily
send them a personal invite so they're
more likely to apply it also gives you a
Competitive Edge against other employers
who may also be interested in that
candidate their user-friendly dashboard
makes it easy to filter review and rate
your candidates all from one place see
how much easier hiring is with
ZipRecruiter 4 out of five employers who
post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day you can
check it out for yourself and see how
well it works go to ziprecruiter.com
Walsh to try ZipRecruiter for free again
that's ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire generally speaking there's three
kind of big buckets of reasons why
someone might engage in intentional
weight loss first is desirability second
Health third stigma hey don't call me
fast but at the end of the day all of
those are rooted in fat phobia in
different ways and I'll explain I can't
wait first desirability that is kind of
the most obvious when it comes to Fat
phobia we currently live in a society
that uplifts thinness it will bodiedness
whiteness cystness and heterosexuality
as the things that are most desirable so
you're always saying there's something
wrong with Society but maybe there's
something wrong with you and so if you
are wanting to lose weight in order to
become more desirable you are upholding
a fat phobic Beauty standard as well as
you know white supremacy and all that
jazz of course
so next is Health what we know is that
weight is a good indicator of someone's
okay we can stop we can stop that please
stop that first of all fat phobia is a
concept
Life's too short to exercise I'm just
gonna be honest actively not wanting to
be fat you're fat phobic oftentimes when
they attach phobia to something
homophobia transphobia it's uh not a
valid
word or concept because no one is afraid
right the the the things that are
labeled transphobia is not fear I'm not
afraid of trans people
how can I be afraid of something that
doesn't exist oh snap you can't actually
be you can claim that you can claim that
identity you can say that about yourself
you can see yourself that way but you
can't actually be that that's not that's
not a that's not that's not an a state
of being that anyone can actually be so
that's not really phobia on the other
hand though fad fobia like yeah that's
okay it makes sense to be afraid of that
not necessarily afraid of fat people but
afraid of fatness afraid of obesity it
makes sense to
have a phobia if you like about that
because it's a very dangerous thing and
it will kill you and it is rather
reasonable to be afraid of things that
will kill you though it's not that
you're worried about a fat person coming
along and killing you
but you're you're worried about yourself
becoming obese and how that would affect
your health
so you should be afraid of that the
other thing you see in the video is just
one of the biggest lies from the left
and it's that they just believe in
living and letting live like they just
want to live their life and they want
you to live your life
it was never the case that was always a
fraudulent claim where now you've got
this woman
who feels perfectly entitled to sit here
and tell you whether it's okay for you
to lose weight she's going to tell you
whether it's okay for you to lose weight
and what are the acceptable reasons for
you to lose weight and what are the
unacceptable reasons so as it turns out
while they pretended they wanted to just
Live and Let Live they actually wanted
to control every aspect of your life and
not just every aspect of your life and
the things you do but what you think
they want to control what you think and
and how you perceive yourself that's
what they want to control not dating
trans people is not a preference not
dating blondes is a preference not
dating people who are I don't know
shorter than five six is a preference
shall I describe it to you
or would you like me to find you a box
now dating people with brown eyes as a
preference being trans is not a specific
characteristic thus you can't label it
as a preference that's just called
bigotry
no one's forcing you to date trans
people but don't cover up your
discriminatory bias in the name of
preference
because the logic doesn't add up like
I've said in many a video the logic of
transphobia never adds up so they're
going to tell you when is it when it's
acceptable for you to lose weight and
what are the acceptable reasons and
they're also going to tell you who
you're allowed to be attracted to so
that was the ultimate that was the the
sort of the final shoe to drop because
that was supposed to be the most sacred
thing of all the most private and
personal thing is your sexual attraction
and nobody should have anything to say
about it no one should have any opinion
about it you could be attracted to
whoever you want in whatever way you
want and that's all there is to it man
everyone's gay once in a while and then
it turns out that well not really
because they they have put themselves in
a position to tell you that it's not
okay to not be a sexually attracted to
transplant you have to be sexually
attracted to trans people they will
berate you until you discover within
yourself a sexual attraction transport
you know if you're a heterosexual man
that means that you're attracted to
females
okay it's not like your entire
attraction is oriented against trans
people that's not relevant not thinking
about that you're attracted to females
and a trans person trans quote-unquote
trans woman a man identified as a female
actually isn't one lefties losing it you
might have a heterosexual man on the
left who pretends to affirm this
person's female identity but in reality
he doesn't
he sees the difference that's what
they're actually upset about is because
they realize that like it take you know
anyone can come along and say oh yeah uh
trans woman trans women are women and
yet the trans activists have noticed
that although a lot of people will say
that I'm not going to say because it's
not true but lots of people will even 99
of the people who say that well they're
not actually when it comes to their own
sexual attraction when it comes to
picking sex partners uh if they're
heterosexual they're picking the
opposite the actual opposite sex no
matter what they claim and uh I think
we've probably seen enough of that we'll
just leave it there and
godspeed up yours woke moralists
[Music]